today at a somewhat rare migration the
person featured yesterday in our opening
monologue has now moved
straight away to our cancellation
monologue that's arkansas governor asa
hutchinson a man
so slight and unimpressive that he makes
eric swalwell look almost masculine by
comparison
and he is the one being canceled today
he was already effectively cancelled
yesterday upon the news that he had
vetoed a bill that would abandon
chemical castration of children in the
state
calling it a quote vast government
overreach to prevent doctors from
generally mutilating children
or giving hormone blockers to children
hutchinson a republican governor in the
south let's remember
took the side of the most fringe and
radical elements of the lgbt left indeed
he took a side did not put five or ten
years ago even many on the lgbt
lgbt left would have opposed or claimed
to oppose
but as we know mainstream conservatism
is often just leftism about a half a
decade behind so
ace hutchinson in this case is right on
schedule
fortunately the arkansas general
assembly performed what you might call
a legislate legislative castration of
the governor by overriding his veto and
enacting the ban anyway hutchinson
apparently decided that he had
not been defrocked and humiliated enough
so he went
on tucker carlson last night to try and
defend his decision to veto the bill
now an intelligent man or at least a man
who cares about his own dignity
might have realized that his position is
literally indefensible as in it cannot
be defended and thus
he would have declined the invitation to
go on cable news the top cable news
program in the country
and try and defend it because he can't
but hutchinson
is not that sort of man and so this is
what happened let's watch
well the legislature in arkansas
recently passed a bill that would ban
doctors from prescribing so-called
puberty blockers heavy-duty hormones to
children
who believe they're transgender the law
also banned
surgeons from physical castration of
children
but the governor of arkansas isa
hutchinson vetoed that bill on monday
legislatures in arkansas just voted to
override
that veto which brings us to where we
are right now ace hutchinson is the
governor of arkansas
and he joins us to talk about this story
governor thanks so much
for coming on i really appreciate it in
the middle of all this
now i i think of you as a conservative
here you've come out
publicly as pro-choice on the question
of chemical castration
okay let's pause there for just a moment
tucker's introduction of the governor
and of the issue is
absolutely fair he summarized things
quite succinctly and accurately
but i want you to just reflect on on
this for a moment this man ace
hutchinson
was either so terrified of upsetting the
far left or so beholden to his corporate
interests or both i think both
that he's willing to be known he's
willing to be known now
as a man who is as tucker said
pro-choice
on the chemical castration of children
he's willing to sit there
his smiling mug presented to the camera
and take
ownership of the view that sometimes
it's good to drug
mutilate and castrate young boys to turn
them into girls
whatever hutchinson thinks that he's
winning as a result of his
self-debasement here
i can guarantee that the reward is not
worth the cost
there's no way it can be so once again a
republican has given up
everything his dignity everything
and in exchange he gets nothing
but it gets worse let's listen now to
his uh his explanation
this bill was overbroad it was extreme
it went far beyond what you just said
and i made it clear that this if this
was about
prohibiting procedures sex reassignment
surgery absolutely i would have signed
that bill but this
again is the first law in the nation
that
uh invokes uh the state between
medical decisions parents who consent to
that
and the decision of the patient and so
this goes
way too far and in fact it doesn't even
have a grandfather clause that
those uh young people that are under
hormonal treatment
i can just correct you for a second well
this is chemical castration of course if
you stop
puberty and suppress the sex hormones
you're chemically castrating someone
so our our description was correct but
let me just ask you
i mean they're all kinds we're talking
about minors children here and there are
all kinds of things in arkansas
kids in every state are not allowed to
do get married drink a beer get a tattoo
why do you think it's important for
conservatives to make certain that
children can block their puberty be
chemically castrated why is that a
conservative value
if you would tell us well first of all
you have
parents involved in very difficult
decisions you have physicians that are
involved in these decisions
and uh i go back to william buckley i go
back to ronald reagan the principles of
our party uh which believes in a limited
role of government
all right there it is there limited role
okay ronald reagan
apparently ronald reagan was
pro-castration
yeah you know i come to think that i i
seem to remember that what was the
famous
reagan quote it was uh mr gorbachev tear
off these balls
now that might be a slight
i'm prouder of that joke that i should
be i really am that might be a slight
paraphrase i don't remember exactly what
the quote was to be honest
in any case hutchinson besides
posthumously recruiting
buckley and reagan into his sex changes
for 12 year olds camp
seems to provide these primary
rationales this is this is the
these are the reasons that he just gave
right
one the government should not interfere
with the decisions of patients
two this is a difficult decision for
parents and doctors and the government
shouldn't interfere with their with that
either
and three we as conservatives should
support limited government and then four
walmart told me to say this now
admittedly point four is more subtext
as for points one through three let's
take them one at a time
first the decision of patience well as
we covered yesterday and i've covered
many times the patients are children
they can't consent they can't make this
decision they're not capable
it is incoherent to say that a 13 year
old
um can you know it's incredibly hard to
say that a 13 year old
cannot consent to sex and yet that he
can consent to a sex
change the same logic
and science psychological and
neurological science that supports the
notion that 13 year olds can't consent
to sex which they can't
also applies just as much if not more so
to sex
changes if you take the one position
you're logically committed to the other
second this is a difficult decision for
parents and doctors now hutchinson here
who calls himself pro-life
is echoing the exact talking points of
the pro-abortion left
we're told that killing babies is a
solemn and difficult decision that
mothers
must sometimes make in consultation with
their doctors
but the difficulty of the decision is
irrelevant
i mean it may be difficult for a wife
who decides to kill her husband
in consultation with her hitman and
maybe it's a difficult and personal
decision
she may agonize over it she may think
long and hard about it
and the thing that but the thing that
makes it difficult
is that murdering your husband is a
terrible thing to do
what makes abortion difficult is that
murdering your child
is a terrible thing to do what makes the
medical transitioning of children
difficult
is that it's a terrible thing to do
in fact in the case of medical
transition and abortion
if these decisions were really what
their proponents describe
if the people on the pro side were
correct in their view
then these decisions shouldn't be
difficult at all
if a baby is nothing but a non-human
lump of meaningless cells why is it
difficult to destroy it
you say it's just a lump of cells okay
well then what do you talk about it's a
difficult decision sounds easy to me
and if a boy really does have a girl
trapped inside him whatever that means
and you can free this this true inner
female identity through medical
procedures
that we're told have no ill effects and
no real downside
then again why is it a difficult
decision
i mean there's a there's a girl trapped
inside there get her out but again
the difficulty is uh is sort of a moot
point in deciding whether the government
has a role
and that brings us to point three
hutchinson says that this is a matter of
limited government which only proves a
point that i've made in the past that
limited government
is a really insufficient and frankly
kind of stupid slogan
for conservatism and you know we've all
shouted it i have too
but limited government has been mostly a
shield for cowards like hutchinson to
hide behind that's really what it is
uh what it's been in practice that's how
it's worked
anytime they encounter a fight that
they're too afraid to get involved in
they can always lift up the banner of
limited government
and um and pretend that they're
deserting the battlefield out of
principle
it's like a soldier who suddenly becomes
a quaker the moment the first bullet
flies
you know he sees that first bullet fly
over his head he says you know what i
think the quakers had a point
you know i'm thinking about it again i
read one of those pamphlets a long time
i think you know i think i sort of i
think i'm a quaker
now limited government conservatives
have in fact at
every level from the presidency on down
expanded the government exponentially
and spent
money by the trillions but then when it
comes to protecting children from the
worst forms of abuse and indoctrination
suddenly they discover their long
dormant passion for
governmental restraint it's a joke and
we should all be too smart to fall for
it
the banner that we should be marching
under is not something vague and over
broad and useless like limited
government but rather something
something that perhaps on second thought
won't fit on a banner at all something
like
we want a government that is properly
ordered and directed
and which uses its power in judicious
lawful and morally sound ways
in order to fulfill its fundamental
obligations to its people
like i said not going to fit on a banner
but the point is that we aren't asking
the government
to uninvolve itself from everything
and one area where the government should
certainly be involved is in the
protection and defense of vulnerable
citizens who cannot protect or defend
themselves
vulnerable citizens such as children who
if they manage to survive the gauntlet
of the modern womb
now face the very real possibility that
they're going to have their minds warped
by radical gender theorists
and then their bodies deformed to match
their warped minds
this is a place for the government to
step in
if this is not a place for government to
step in then i can't imagine
where else government should step in if
this is not a job for the government
then what
could be a job for the government if we
if we uh
you know restrain government here then
how can we justify exerting the
government
anywhere else
we can't i mean that's clear it's clear
even to ace hutchinson
but he's decided to pretend that he
doesn't understand what he certainly
does
understand and for that today
we must transition asa hutchinson to the
status of
cancelled listen hit that subscribe
button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated